You're Ryota Sato.
Who are you? Sorry,
sister. I think this person is right.
What's this guy? He's a good-looking guy with two beautiful women. Is there
something he wants from me? I want to arm-wrestle with you. Why,
arm-wrestler-kun?  I'm interested in the power of someone.I
heard that you were
doing something extravagantly the other day.I wonder if you're going to have a
one-on-one match with me.He's good-looking,
feminine, and confident in his powers.I can't forgive him.I
understand,
thank you.Okay, let's
go,
ladies.  [
Applause] This
guy is strong.
[Music] He
lost. That's
amazing, you, you
too. I see.
Doesn't this guy know about Neptune? This
is the most powerful organization in Cyclo.
Neptune. I
won't do it again.
Stop making any more noise.  It looks like it's going to be
[Music]
Well, it can't be
helped. Then, what do you mean? No, I'm not going to do it, you. I
like it. If you like, you
can join my family. Ha, are you
serious?